[Music]
before sack Schneider turned one of the
most universally beloved comics of all
time into a completely polarizing movie
he turned to the most universally
beloved comic of all time into a
completely polarizing movie Watchmen
you've read the dark satirical comic now
get ready for the movie adaptation that
transforms the complex characters and
grounded realistic action into a gory
version of the matrix in a film that
Watchmen creator Alan Moore described as
regurgitated worms then again the guy
worships a snake so take it with a grain
of salt when it comes to most spiritual
beliefs Fox props war worship a second
century human headed snake God called
glutton stare in awe as Snyder's
gorgeous shots carry you through an
overstuffed clod where a dense 13
chapter series is crammed into a single
movie full of so many story threads it
feels like marathoning an entire season
of lost jobs at the same time me darken
versions of heroes you know and love who
do their best to fight crime and
maintain an erection like the comedian
who's Captain America if he were a dick
Rorschach who's Batman if he were a dick
and dr. Manhattan who's Superman if he
were a dick who always had his dick
hanging out seriously
always
so many dicks there were only three dick
shots in the entire comic an animator
had to spend hours getting the dicks wet
just right
I'd move on but it's really hard to
focus on anything when there's a big
blue tick of the screen experience
Jackie Earle Haley spot-on performance
as a smelly hobo who hates hands Moloch
I break another finger as he shines
alongside a cast that does their
comic-book counterparts justice
despite some on the nose dialog that old
person make up I'm 67 years old and the
presence of Malin Akerman you want me to
see things your way go ahead show me do
that thing you do we don't normally like
to call out actors and she seems like a
really nice person at all but this is
just I have a real name I've been using
a couple years now trying she makes
Matthew Goode look okay prepare for a
two hour and 40 minute movie it's closer
to two without all the slow-mo full of
everything Zack Snyder carried over into
his next two DC movies like Rey sex
Jesus allegories graphic violence
apocalyptic dream sequences and
justifying the destruction of a major
metropolis killing millions to save
billions but if that's not Snyder E
enough check out a director's cut that
adds more graphic violence
more sex and more Jesus allegories but
if even that's not Snyder enough spring
for the Ultimate Edition where two
characters who don't like each other
come to the shocking realization that
they have the same name you know all
this time you've been coming here I
never caught your name
not that's so that's where he got it
from so get ready for one of the most
self-serious films ever made
that keeps shoehorning in a heavy vase
and features some of the most depressing
humorless characters in film
arguing over what is and isn't a joke
that's the real joke I can never tell on
you joking joke by her joke joke is
practical joke in human history that's
the real practical joke good joke
everybody laugh huh starring Harvey
Birdman homeless man man silk spectra
The Killing Joke VAX head wound Zack
Snyder making Zack Snyder references
foreshadowing
Yvonne muss and don't you know I'm
electro dr. Manhattan or how I learned
to stop worrying and love the dog I'll
bet dr. Manhattan would have won Vietnam
even sooner if he'd taken that thong off
talk about intimidation boss be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers I
have no father I was brought to life by
Zeus your scratchy squirrel voice has
nothing on my sexy buttery cow voice
wacky waving inflatable arm-flailing
tube-man monster monster trucks
featuring Bigfoot and smogzilla sunday
sunday sunday be there none of you seem
to understand I'm not locked in here
with you
you're locked in here with me
Rorschach's journal October 12 1895
tonight a comedian died in New York